there's a lot of conservative agitation
not just libertarian but the urban of
agitation to revive that idea and you
know I don't know what what judge were
six teens to this but I would be
guardedly optimistic that he's a friend
of that hi I'm Nicolas be with Reason TV
and today we're talking with Randy
Barnett and we're talking about the
newest Supreme Court nomination Neil
Gorsuch Randy thanks for talking to us
you're at Georgetown Law immediate
reaction neil Gorsuch good good or bad
choice well we knew the president was
going to pick from this list of twenty
one and so uh that's our universe of
comparison and of all the people on that
list he was certainly near the top of
that list mm-hmm
what does that mean though in terms of
like obviously and Trump has this weird
tick of like really enough somebody's
resume like oh you know good Trump went
to Penn that's a Ivy League school he
talked about Harvard and Harvard and
more Harvard and than some Oxford but is
Gorsuch from a libertarian point of view
is he the guy that we want to you know
be effectively the deciding vote and a
lot of Supreme Court cases well next
what 50 or you know 35 years because
he's 49 years old let's start with
qualifications of a more conventional
Seward the guy is super smart he's
experienced as a court of appeals judge
he he's a good writer and he has a great
educational background Columbia Harvard
Law School and a DPhil from Oxford where
he studied under John finished the
famous natural law philosopher so that's
this is good from a libertarian
perspective because natural law is the
thing that kind of puts limits on the
government enumerated unenumerated it's
just the idea that the government can't
control all aspects of our life it has a
famous book called natural law natural
rights there's not natural law natural
rights are not the same thing and
finnish knows there's a difference
presumably corsets does as well
Fitness is not my cup of tea when it
comes to natural law thinking
he's quite conservative and he's I don't
think he's very libertarian and it and
for putting his politics to one side his
philosophy is not my cup of tea when it
comes to natural law but if you asked me
if I would like a justice who thinks
respectfully of natural law understands
it has some understanding of it and sort
of thinks it's not nonsense and nonsense
or nonsense on stilts
it was jeremy bentham's phrase for it i
would say that's a pretty big plus and
different than other justices that we've
had or that we're on that list so do you
think that I mean one of your big causes
is having justices who will strike down
laws that take you know take rights away
from individuals to make decisions in
their lives like that that grow the
government's power do you think or such
will be an ally in that well I think we
need to talk deal with the candidacy as
a whole so I started with basic
qualifications credentials
accomplishments smarts writing ability
so the judicial Harriet Miers judicial
yes he's got his he does have somewhat
of a record judicial courage is also
very important we've seen what happens
when judges lack courage to go up
against conventional wisdom all of these
are qualities that you want to see in
the Justice before you get to judicial
philosophy which is what you are asking
me about I believe judicial philosophy
is part of the qualifications it's not
over you don't just put somebody on
whose quote qualified and Romaric Garlin
who is my classmate at harvard is
supremely qualified but he has a
judicial philosophy to which i object
right nevertheless but you do want your
judges to be competent you want them to
be mollified plus okay so first of all I
think judge Gorsuch ticks off the
qualified yes so that's big and that's
not a small thing with Trump because
people I mean are dealing with a
president who it seems to not really
give a [ __ ] about you know that type of
stuff so it's a good sign that he he
went through he picked a guy who is
eminently pre-qualified then we get to
the judicial philosophy it's a great
sign because we going through the
campaign we first of all we didn't know
if he would stick to his list right so
he keeps his promise
mmm-hmm a guy who keep it's kind of
different kind of a change of pace yeah
and so he keeps his promise he sticks to
the list and he's prepared to pick a guy
who's sort of smarter than he is yeah
let's face it I mean and he may we
didn't first of all every president
who's picked a good judge is typically
pick one who's smarter than they are
but question do I do are they internally
self-confident enough to do that no
apparently Donald Trump is okay we
didn't know that yeah that's good yeah
so that's good now you you're dying to
get to judicial philosophy that's really
where you wanna go you're all about
results Nick you're talking don't go
into journaling a results-oriented
journalist so we can't put you on the
court the truth of the matter is we
don't know there are three I would say
there are three components that you're
apart from judicial courage there are
three substantive components that I
would be looking for that I would want
to see there's three boxes the
originalist box the precedent box
willing to reverse precedent box and the
unenumerated Liberties privileges or
immunities and or due process economic
Liberty what box there's a three
separate box was interrelated but you
could check off one in the other he
let's take the first box which in some
respects gets you to the others
yeah he is by far in a way a committed
originalist know he is written about
originally first of all he's a acolyte
of Justice and admirer of Justice Scalia
right who ticks off that box well Scalia
didn't tick off the other two boxes
right away so well yeah so it's not like
Scalia's a sealing Scalia in some
respects provides us with a floor right
so Gorsuch ticks off the box not only
does he say he's an originalist but in
his opinions he refers to interpreting
the text according to which original
public meaning right that is the state
of the art of originalist theory that I
proposed so there's the old original
framers intent mm-hmm people still talk
like that if they don't know what
they're talking about
he says original public meaning it means
he knows what he's talking about and he
understands what that that's the end he
wants to be on and that truthfully in
fairness is what
Justice Scalia was four right and he
promoted it there's no plumbing
so that's box number one that's good and
he seemed and he said repeatedly that's
how we should approach things
the precedent box we don't know mmm-hmm
don't know I don't there is some
rumbling Ilya somin had a piece on the
Bala conspiracy which found a piece by
him I think it must have been an essay
which he praised the New Deal justices
for their restraint and I don't know
when that was I don't know if his
thinking is changed by the way the
thinking of conservatives have changed
at one of this in recent years we don't
know if his thinking has changed or not
but anyway that wasn't great when I read
that but we just don't know and you know
what we're not going to find out right
one reason is because Court of Appeals
judges actually do try to follow
precedent and they should yeah so
they're doing their job especially if
they have higher aspirations yeah and
they don't have to follow precedent when
they get on the court and we'll know
whether when he gets there if he chooses
to and we won't know that before and
doesn't matter what he's asked at his
confirmation hearings we won't know bro
the third box is the due process
privilege immunities our economic
liberties box and here again a we don't
know but B I would not be optimistic
about this I wouldn't be because you're
not optimistic about anybody in that
situation should I pretty much if unless
I know yeah and like judge Justice Don
Willett of a Supreme Court who's shown
some interest in this era but unless I
have some reason to think so I'm not
optimistic he could surprise us i if he
surprised us you know it would be a
surprise yeah and that's it so look we
you can't we it's hard to expect that a
Republican president of any kind of Ted
Cruz were picking you know I think we
would be less likely to get somebody who
takes that box then Donald Trump picked
a who isn't really aware of it Ted Cruz
is aware of it he's very likely to
choose against it so what what do you
think about now that will have a full
Supreme Court roster of nine justices
are they going to are they going to be a
significant factor in what is shaping up
as a trump presidency that
seems to be interested in having a
president who has a lot of power are
they going to be pushing back against
that are they going to be pushing back
against Congress we hear you know there
are rumblings in Congress that they're
gonna take back power from the executive
branch what what is your you know kind
of prophecy of the Supreme Court over
the next four years the president has
been given enormous discretionary power
by congressional statute for a very long
time I don't think Donald Trump is doing
anything that's not authorized by
statute the soda whole idea of running
around saying what he's doing is
unconstitutional of what he's doing is
illegal I haven't seen any good argument
for a why it's illegal and be why it's
unconstitutional even as it might be
unwise yeah the idea that you have a
policy disagreement you have the
president exercising his discretion is
to be expected
yeah of a Republican or a Democrat right
but I don't see any great sign that this
is going to be any more of an imperial
presidency than Barack Obama's
presidency was but we should point out
that's a bad presidency right an
imperial presidency is it I mean it's
taken for granted but it's a bad yes
although libertarians seem to get a lot
more incensed about Republicans imperial
president than they do about Democrat
for whatever reason yeah I don't know
ask them okay that's me that's my
experience but Judge Gorsuch one of the
things he's quite well known for and
Damen root points this out in his recent
piece is he's quite well known for his
antipathy towards what's called Chevron
deference which is deference to the
interpretation of statutes by
administrative agencies which is a
doctrine that Justice Scalia is strongly
supported and which I criticized in my
book I quote Justice Thomas as critical
of that form of deference and there's
other forms of deference as well that
Justice Thomas is critical of a judge
Gorsuch is quite vocally critical of
that so that means he's less deferential
to administrative agencies which means
he's less deferential to the executive
branch right
to answer your question do you then
Scalia was do you throw Scalia was
coming around in his later years to this
position and Chevron
reference I you know at first when I
heard that I was like oh that must be an
ancient legal term but it's really about
the oil company right Chevron do you is
this the moment where Justice Clarence
Thomas really becomes a kind of dominant
voice on the Supreme Court or what do
you think Gorsuch will be falling in
line with Thomas or well Thomas you know
kind of dominate a you know opinions
going forward or does it even make sense
and talk that way could talk that way I
don't know I think just you know just a
judge corsets a former Kennedy Clerk I
think his arguments are gonna have a lot
more play with Justice Kennedy than
Justice Scalia's ever did oh so I see I
see and and in in terms of his general
persona he reminds me a bit of Justice
Roberts and he's got this you know
clean-cut Harvard you know God persona
so I don't know who he's where he's
gonna we don't know yeah yeah you know
we're gonna find out and we're not gonna
know before he becomes a justice a lot
of people on the left so can I say one
more yeah sure he gave a big lecture at
at the Federal Society in 2013 which
unfortunately I had to miss which is too
bad to miss I usually go to all the
Olson lectures and I miss that one in
which he complained about the over
criminalization of over federal
criminalization of activities yeah now
that's not really going to affect his
performance as a justice it tells us a
little bit about where he's coming from
one of the things he does he has done in
his opinions is he has said he has
endorsed the Scalia view that said
people should not be going to sent to
the penitentiary unless the state can
prove mens rea or criminal intent with
respect to every element of the offense
and he said there are people in the
penitentiary who have not been proven to
be guilty of mens rea of every element
and that means among other things that
they are particularly that they know
they were committing a crime they know
they were committing the crime for which
they're convicted so for example if
you're convicted as a felon committing a
robbery with a gun mm-hmm then what
judge course have said is you need to
know you're a felon you need to know
you're committing a foul
right and if you didn't know you were
committing a felony then that's that's
one of the elements of a sign that's a
more rights protective criminal justice
rights protective attitude than other
justices it's what Justice Scalia is
known for and you know what it's more
rights protective than anything we could
expect from Merrick garland right right
who was Obama's pick who didn't get a
hearing right
do you people liberals Democrats talk a
lot about okay well you know in the end
everything about the Supreme Court has
to do with Roe versus Wade is there any
reason to believe the Supreme Court will
be revisiting the basics of abortion to
find reason to believe okay yeah I I
mean do you do you think over the next
couple of years we're gonna have a major
abortion decision I think they easily
could yeah sure
this is you know the ROE versus Wade is
not settled right and it's not is a
sociological matter right it's not and
III assume that you believe in abortion
right or reproductive rights for women
the only yeah the issue but the issue of
course the constitutional issue is
whether the federal government gets to
prohibits state laws that regulate right
matter the Federalist position the
Federalist Society Justice Scalia's
position has never been that probe the
total pro-life position the total
pro-life position is that the taking of
a human life violates the 14th amendment
take life without due process of law
therefore abortion is illegal to you
know you're right that's never been
Justice Scalia's position there's never
been the conservative position it goes
back to the goes back to the states and
then it has to be fought as a policy
matter and according to state
constitutional laws state Supreme
Court's will then weigh yet right so
that is your that is your worst-case
scenario mm-hm it's not that some
pro-life advocates wouldn't want more
than that but that's never been on the
table and could that happen in the next
five or ten years I think it could
happen I think it could do because
what's settled in what's not settled is
a social construct it's not there's an
there's no objective not a scientific
fact just about settled and roe v wade
has never
settled in the center of that it's never
been not contested right it's been
contested since it was decided right as
a result I can see them
undoing it and sending it back to the
States talk a little bit about the thing
that would bother me about that is that
if it's just the reason why they'd be
what would be the reasoning would be the
reasoning is that if you can't find a
right in the Constitution then there is
no such right well you know I don't
agree with that I think the mere fact
that a right is not in the Constitution
doesn't tell you whether it's protected
or right because it doesn't tell you
with it whether Congress or the states
have the power to regulate in the first
place and that's likely their reasoning
and that reasoning I won't like but the
bottom line is they think they could
revisit it what what what are we missing
with the passing of Antonin Scalia on
the Supreme Court and what do we gain I
mean because he obviously was a legal
giant he was a very oversized
personality his his opinions mattered
you know more than me to most justices
what do we miss from him dying and being
off the bench and what do we gain as a
possible well for a rather small man he
was bigger than life yeah and I knew him
years ago when I was the University of
Chicago when I was a research fellow I
got to know him had lunch with him but
didn't really know him wasn't a friend
of his and I got to DC and I was with
him more he came to my class once at my
seminar at Georgetown he gave his talk
about his book and I introduced him at
several speeches he gave at Georgetown I
had dinners with him I got to know him
and really liked him a lot and it was
quite shaken actually by Ross surprising
to me but he was a larger-than-life
figure he was he was a lion he was
courageous he would take no quarter he
would give no quarter
he asked for no quarter he gave him the
quarter and he would debate anybody any
and he was all about the ideas mm-hmm
and that's great
and he was a absolute stalwart robust
defender of originalism even if he
himself did not practice it right
consistently or even if if he believed
that precedent can override originalism
in ways I don't believe right now
less without justice scalia's leadership
intellectual leadership I don't think
originalism would be on people's lips
today I listened to a morning talk radio
host who I happen to like here in DC and
on my way over here and he said well you
know Gorsuch is an originalist Bubba but
that port would not have becoming a
doubt that I mean Scully before it
Scalia justices didn't even really refer
to the law right I mean like they would
be like yeah you know we think it's this
or that but they didn't look at the text
right and that's he changed he
single-handedly changed the practice of
law at the Supreme Court level and made
them textualist and Gorsuch is
absolutely a generalist and you know we
do better
I just think libertarians do better
under the Constitution is written then
under the Constitution that has been
given us by post New Deal judges right I
think we do better under the real one
and under the pretend one and so if you
follow the real one the more you follow
it the better off we are right now how
much will they follow it so what is the
opening though of in a post Scalia
Supreme Court I mean is there space
particularly for libertarians you know
and we have been coming off people were
bothered libertarians were bothered by
George Bush's kind of you know expansive
understanding of his executive power
Obama pushed that even more Donald Trump
seems to be very interested in like
being in charge you know well well we
see a Supreme Court that pulls back on
that or is that not the Supreme Court's
role anyway if there's certain doctrines
that Supreme Court could start to revive
and it would have an effect one of them
call the non delegation doctrine which
says Congress cannot delegate its
legislative powers to the executive
branch which it has been doing since the
30s it's Congress has been doing that
and the court just says okay it's okay
right
they could be enforcing that better and
there's a lot of conservative agitation
not just libertarian but the derivative
agitation to revive that idea and you
know I don't know what what judge nor
succeeds to this but I would be
guardedly optimistic that he's a friend
of that
because as he says in his critical
criticism of Chevron legislators are the
ones that should be legislating right
the problem of the delegation is that
they're delegating their legislative
power to another branch and his
objection to Chevron is separation of
powers and that's the same objection you
make to this delegation so there's every
his intellectual framework would lead
him to be critical of that that's good
for us
I mean it it's not good in terms of it
still respects what Congress does right
but at least Congress has to do it right
not faceless nameless unaccountable
bureaucrats right which his mother was
well she was not faceless we're no yeah
no she was that who could be named but
she was an EPA Administrator on right
under Reagan so well that'll bit that'll
be interesting to play it let me ask you
as a final question your book our
republican constitution did it have the
effect that you wanted I mean of like
pulling back to an understanding of you
know the idea that that Congress should
be legislating and Congress should be
doing its job the court should be
striking down laws that you know that
crowd out individual autonomy and
everything are you are you happy with
the effect of the book and what comes
next for you well it's too soon to tell
you know because people read it and it
either affects them or not I think the
timing of the book it's about a year or
two later than it should have been mmm
if it had become out two years earlier
before the presidential season heated up
it might have had a chance to influence
the race more than it did mhm so that's
too bad but look I couldn't write it
right until I thought of it and I wrote
it so but I think I think I think all
the efforts that those of us associated
for the Institute for justice or Damon
rude the the the people the Damon root
has written about right I think we've
had a big effect on the conservative
legal culture yeah by some accounts
we're winning in the war of ideas the
problem with when and and by winning
it's that you're getting people who
would identify as conservative to say
you know what like justices need to be
more active in saying you know the
government doesn't get to make these
decisions
need to be active that that judges knee
you know that judges need to defend
natural rights
well not expressly but that judges need
to robustly enforce the text of the
Constitution and then the next step
would be including the provisions that
are abstract like the privileges or
immunities clause something like that
like Justice Thomas did in his Macdonald
case when he said privilege and
immunities is where this belongs so I
think we're winning people are less
afraid the Obamacare case was a
political watershed it was an inflection
point where people went oh you know this
judicial restraint I'm not so sure I
like that so much anymore yeah the
question and I think judges have been
affected by that so perhaps judge
Gorsuch was they all we all lived
through this one big huge fantastic
three day of argument case together a
couple of the judges who wimped out the
lower court judges weren't even on the
list of 21
they were Supreme Court in Waiting
themselves I don't want to name names
but they didn't make it to the list of
21 I think that's because the people who
are putting together the list didn't
like the wimping out there so yeah we
were winning in that regard however just
think about it anybody who gets
nominated today is going to be in their
50s he's 49 they he got his political
legal jurisprudential principles 20
years ago before when people like me and
Roger Palin and other people we were
like outliers right we're we're still in
a battle but we're not as big of
outliers maybe we've got the wind at our
back but you know they got their
principles back in those days there's a
lag there's a long time so I was asked
online on Twitter by somebody who who
asked me you know okay and it's like too
bad you know make me feel better about
you like the fact that that you know
what about unenumerated rights right
stuff I said hey look you can't always
get what you want
but if you try sometimes you just might
find you can't wait to get what you need
yeah so well talked you know about the
the roll I mean that you I mean you had
personally and people like Roger plumb
but also then the federal
Society of this sea change and the
institutions the intellectual
institutions that have changed people's
mind that's because log moved slowly
right I mean it and it should move
slowly but this is you're talking about
a revolution that is really like you
know 50 years in the making
yeah and I'm look I'm a big I'm big
active in the federal society I do a lot
with them for them I threw in with them
they're a coalition of libertarians and
conservatives or a coalition of people
you called restraint people as an honor
to coalition but you know that's just
you know if the Federal Society helped
give us Neil Gorsuch they also gave us
John Roberts they did yeah I think that
some of the people that may have been
responsible that regret that decision
wrote but time you live and you learn
yeah I was I've been around and others
like me have been around to say hey look
here's why the book my book is about
this is what we got on this my book is
about here's why this happened I
couldn't have written that book before
Obamacare because it's about here's why
you lost this case the Conservatives got
their way and you lost with your guys
yeah look for different guys so I think
this time around they really were
looking for different guys whether they
were looking for a person who thinks due
process protects economic liberty or
privilege amenities I'm skeptical yeah I
think they were looking for somebody
with judicial courage mm-hmm and I found
it well we will we will find out well
it'll take us years to know you know all
right well we will leave it there we
won't find out as a result of the
hearings I'll tell you that okay it'll
take us years to well you'll be watching
that as a you know as a legal yeah Joel
I mean like yeah like it's like a
Supreme Court porn yeah we gotta watch
it they got you can't take your eyes off
the screen ya know it's yeah well and
with that horrible thought in our minds
we will end it but we've been talking
with Randy Barnett of Georgetown Law his
most recent book is our republican
constitution which has a just a I don't
want to say it's about a stripper but
like that opening section where you talk
about
you know Obamacare and how you got
involved in that is like just incredible
I mean it's like I just wish I'd have
put bodice-ripping in there yeah cover
on the cover you get Fabio on the cover
we have been talking with Randy Barnett
I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason TV thanks
for watching
[Music]